la jolla california i'll be at the la
jolla comedy store august 5th through
the 7th philadelphia pennsylvania i'll
be there august 18th through the 20th
austin texas i will be there september
2nd through the third get your tickets
for those shows and all shows on my
website at ryanzigler.com
the honeydew with ryan zickler
[Applause]
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i'm ryan sickler ryan
sickler.com ryan sickler on all social
media and again i want to say thank you
thank you for
watching the show subscribing to this
show for supporting this show you're
legitimately changing my life and it i
couldn't be more thankful for real so if
you are watching hit hit subscribe on
youtube it's free it's a free way to
help the show all right and if you got
to have more you got to check out the
patreon it's called the honeydew with
y'all i highlight the lowlights with you
all and their stories like you've never
heard in your life i promise you that
it's five bucks a month if you sign up
for a year you get over a month free and
you're getting the honey do a day early
ad free at no additional cost all right
if you or someone you know has that
story that has to be heard please submit
it to honeydewpodcast gmail.com alright
i'll be in la jolla august 5th through
7th philadelphia august 18th through the
20th in austin september 2nd and 3rd
that's labor day weekend so get your
tickets to that and all shows at
ryansickler.com now that's all the biz
you guys know what we do here
we highlight the low lights i always say
these are the stories behind the
storytellers and i am very excited
to finally have this guest
first time here on the honeydew y'all
please we've worked
bobby lee yeah welcome to the how do you
do bobby
bro i did your thing other one the crab
crab you did the craft feast yeah so
it's not like it's not my first time on
the honeydew it is but okay which i said
that's right that's fine but can i ask
you a question sure do you like this
melon oh no
the the green melon is that what the is
that what honeydew is that's what
honeydew is the whole point of it very
quickly because i've said it a lot but i
do want to you don't have to get into it
if you can tell me off screen no
off screen or off we're in a movie yeah
um
i was eating at a diner one night and
they had that fruit cup there and i ate
everything in the fruit cup except for
the honeydew including the red grapes
which i don't i like green grapes but i
ate red grapes over the honeydew yeah
and when i got up and i walked out i saw
honeydew scattered on all the tables and
i just thought man that's a perfectly
good fruit that most of us just
[ __ ] off we'll pass yeah and then it
dawned on me that in life i am that i'm
a perfectly good person that's been
thrown away and tossed away again and
again and again it's funny so i wanted
to lean into the [ __ ] show because
instead of everyone's highlights look at
my life i'm on a yacht i'm onto this
like i want to know when you weren't on
a [ __ ] yacht right when you were on
your knees right so what i'm saying is
is that what i'm i wasn't saying
anything but my point is is that my
point is is this is i know that i know
you and you say a lot of things like
so-and-so didn't give me you know
respect back then or he ignored me or
this because i i have the same thing i
have a list of people i'm gonna get
revenge on right but don't you think a
lot of that is in our minds i think a
lot no i i well yes because we do think
it it's in our minds however it's
happened you can't deny it everyone sure
everyone's gets disrespected and [ __ ] on
all the time yeah but i don't i don't
hol so here's the thing i told you
before we were talking i don't
harbor
ill feelings i use it as fuel to move
forward yeah you know what i mean like
go ahead but also most of the people
that big time to me and
i they've all turned out to be [ __ ]
shows you know what i mean like
yeah the one thing that's been how old
are you now i'm 49 we're the same age
it's been 50. it's one of the lessons
that's taken me longest to learn in life
and i still slip up here and there is
that
most things take care of themselves
i don't have to jump in and say this and
do that
but let me just have a point though so i
was at keegan's keegan keys birthday
party
and ron howard was there
i'm a big ron howard fan [ __ ] yeah right
and so i was like telling kalyla i was
like i gotta say something right she's
like don't just ignore it right and so
he was at the buffet
and i love apollo
as apos i said i love apollo right he
just kind of walked away with a thing
yeah he kind of just walked away with
thing right and i got about 30 and he
was gone but
he was gone right my point is is that he
number one he probably didn't hear it
right number two probably gets it all
the time right so it's like normally i
would be like i'm going to take that
person i'm going to get revenge and run
over but right
right but at the end of the day
he probably didn't hear it and you know
it's a party
he's got other people right no what
that's what he knows is that but i know
that dudes come up to me and go
i've heard like bobby lee's an [ __ ]
and they go why because oh well he's you
know i said i've met him three times and
you know i mean he doesn't remember me
or whatever like that but it's like
something that i'm not really privy to
or i'm aware of my point is is that in
life right
you know maybe it's a lot of it just
lives in our head
yeah well i did shows with you and knew
you for well over a decade and then when
i got to work with you individually yeah
on the comedy jam you were like who are
you and but
that's what yeah but but i don't really
remember that but also i didn't take it
personally because i know
that is how it is
some people are they're they're
everyone's got the look just because
we're we're co-workers at the end of the
day if you strip away what we do because
what we do i do believe is magical and
it's [ __ ] awesome yeah but at the end
of the day if you just classify it as a
job
okay we're just co-workers all of us are
co-workers that's true you know so
you've got some of these guys
we're in a big corporation that's it
with a lot of people that working there
that's right yeah i got to know
everybody nope so or not you'll know
them hey hey jan yeah hey whatever how's
this how's that but you know outside of
that you don't
text talk hang out but
so brian simpson you know him mm-hmm
i remember a time where for a couple
years i never even looked at the dude
right
i go is that a homeless black man
in my head right and then all of a
sudden like i could see him rise
you see him rise right and i it's
nothing that i'm i'm not going out of my
way to do it i just would find myself in
conversations with him and just being
i'd see him perform i go god this guy's
really good and over the years and then
like he was in austin we were doing some
festival i don't know whatever moon moon
tower and he was sitting there outside
of the hotel it was like six in the
morning he had just partied and he just
got i had already slept
and he didn't look good so i kind of
walked up to i rubbed his back and i go
you know hey you should get some sleep
by giving advice and you think so i go
yeah you you look weird you know what i
mean and i was i was concerned for him
right but the whole time in my head it's
like i've been ignoring this guy i
ignored this guy for years right so it's
just like i've been analyzing that in my
head like what is that about the human
condition when you see somebody rise to
your level and then all of a sudden you
change but i don't like that about
myself but is that
is that what we are
i don't know i try to treat everybody
the same from the get-go because you
never know who's gonna rise yeah yeah
you know what i mean yeah but also
i think this you know what let me focus
for one second would please plug and
promote everything you would like to do
right now all your shows why why now
cause i always do it at the top and i do
want to do that because i'm here for the
comedian wow instead of people who wait
two hours yeah plug it now and then
everybody's like can i do it in like 10
minutes you can do whatever the [ __ ] you
want i want you to know what we're doing
you know
that's another thing i don't want to
change about myself when people tell me
to do something i won't do it but i want
to change that about myself i'm going to
ask you so ask me to do another
absolutely no i will will you please i
will and i will i will all right so um
yeah i got nothing no
no i have uh
you know i'm on two podcasts tiger belly
and um
bad friends with andrew centino and then
um
in august i guess i'm in a show called
reservation dog second season and um
i mean i have a bunch of other things
but they're not coming out yet so yeah
that's good good
all right yeah um
so what let's talk about what well
you tell me if we're allowed to talk
about it yeah when i saw you said uh
because i had said i've never met kalila
i love her i want to say this okay
ten years ago when i met her on tinder
my career was
in the [ __ ] like
like i was literally about to get let go
of my agency and
i wasn't bringing up any income i wasn't
getting any auditions i would
sporadically over the years maybe we'll
book a pilot or something right but it
was like nothing really
intended to work out for me and i you
know i would see other people rise and i
was literally at a point where i was
like you know what i gotta change
something about
how i view my business and and and not
to make it like my number one thing
you know because you know when you make
your business your number one thing it's
just a lot of pain that goes along with
that right and life is not about that
so i you know decided to pour my
attention into a relationship and i met
kalila at the perfect time and um
you know in many ways she's the love of
my life i um she reinvented my career
um we started tiger belly with nothing
we just bought
equipment from guitar center and we just
started doing it this was about eight
nine years ago and um
and
it grew
you know it grew and it helped other
aspects of my business and now like you
know i'm selling show i have a couple of
shows i sold and you know i'm i'm in i
have a pretty big movie i'm coming you
know i mean just things are happening
and i really equate that to um
you know the dedication
of kalila in me her investment in me and
my investment in her
and um
she is the love of my life and i love
her dearly and um she changed me in so
many different ways
that being said um
we broke up
yeah yeah yeah yeah and this is the
first time
you know i don't know if this is we'll
hold this episode until you hold it
right now we'll not swallow it yeah yeah
because i really would like to meet her
i saw her for 10 seconds at christina's
party yeah and you as well you came in
bowed to me and bounced and then i was
like what about
i was dressed like i was from the 80s
yeah yeah i don't know what it was
it was dark is that a magical gnome and
uh um
and i would love to have her on here too
yeah but uh i did not know you you guys
broke up no one knows this is the first
time i've talked about it well
we'll hold this episode yeah this
literally is the first time i've talked
about it on a podcast
um hopefully my other one would have
aired by now that people kind of know
but um
it was a
long difficult decision between us
and um we still live together that's
what you said they were still living
sleep on the same bed we still laugh and
giggle and um
we're going to the philippines soon
because we're working on a project
together um
yeah i mean nothing's really changed
outside of the fact that we're not you
know um a comm in a committed
relationship as boyfriend and girlfriend
um
that might change i don't know i mean
but right now
we're we feel
good
i mean i can only speak for myself you
know i mean i feel pretty good about it
um it's painful
it's hard i mean when you're in a
relationship with someone that you love
that hard for 10 years
10 years yeah but a lot of things that
went on you know um
and you know people follow the internet
you know and follow
my story you know a lot went on in the
last
year but it's you know honestly it was
mostly my fault
and i'll tell you why um
a couple years ago
maybe three years ago before the
pandemic um
i could see myself out of the
relationship in terms of like
giving her what she needs you know women
they need cuddles they need attention
they need intimacy they need all that
and i was not giving her anything i was
just playing video games and like
watching porn all day you know what i
mean and she would say
every day she would cry and be like what
about me what's going on and i'd just be
like i'm just not i don't know i'm going
through something i would make some some
sort of excuse you know and um in the
last two or three years we had sex maybe
twice what yeah
and
she would always want and i just for
some reason i think
getting
so you're saying you're not just
watching porn you're jerking off you're
self-satisfying yours no i want you for
the cinematography what the [ __ ] are you
talking about
oh you said what yeah yeah yeah but
you're
self-satisfying everything the video
games the comedy the porn
and she's like what about me yeah and i
would have three times in two to two
years
yeah
wow you know you you reflect at your
behavior and what caused all this and um
she's getting a lot of things on the
internet you know i mean
and i have to play i have to
take 95 of the blame really i think you
know i really believe that
um i mean
i'm with you that's good everything is
getting more expensive including rent
prices are skyrocketing all over the
country and buying a home might feel
scary right now but it could be your
most stable option i highly recommend
checking out the how to buy a home
podcast host david cedoni is an industry
expert with years of experience who is
devoted to helping first-time home
buyers navigate this crazy marketplace
and he can help you did you know there's
a difference between interest rates and
mortgage rates david will break it all
down for you he's also shared pro tips
and tricks to navigate this insanely
competitive landscape how to buy a home
is an incredible resource and you don't
even have to take notes david's how to
buy a home podcast has helped so many
listeners close on houses that they
thought were impossible even as things
went bonkers in 2021 and 2022. if you're
thinking about buying a home next month
next year in five years david can help
you too he can even connect you with a
great realtor in your area look i'm
about to talk to david and i know so
many of you have already i've had people
come up to me at shows but we bought our
first house because of you that's blows
me away and he wouldn't still be coming
back here promoting if if you weren't
y'all so start your path today with the
how to buy home podcast and make this
the last year you rent listen to the how
to buy home podcast today find how to
buy a home on youtube and wherever you
listen to podcasts the hot summer months
are here and we need to be proactive
about keeping our bodies fueled and
hydrated one stick of liquid iv and 16
ounces of water hydrates you two times
faster and more efficiently than water
alone listen i love liquid iv i'm taking
that every single day we have it here at
the studio i'm giving it out it shows
all right i'm giving it to anybody i
know that asks tom segura security got
some what's up marcus what i like most
about liquid iv is how easy it is to
take along with you no matter where you
are you just drop it in and you're good
to go it really is that easy and one
stick of liquid iv hydration multiplier
and 16 ounces of water hydrates faster
and more efficiently than water alone it
contains five essential vitamins it's
got b3 b5 b6 b12 and vitamin c with
three times the electrolytes of
traditional sports drinks it's made with
premium ingredients non-gmo and free
from gluten dairy and soy grab liquid iv
in bulk nationwide at costco or you can
get 25 off when you go to liquidive.com
and use the code honeydew at checkout
that's 25 off of anything you order when
you shop better hydration today using
promo code honeydew at
liquidive.com now let's get back to the
do i regret so many things
i regret so many things you know i
regret a lot of things i'm not even
specifically to her i've i've regretted
things in my life in my career
in other ways you know i mean there's a
lot of regret there but at the end of
the day
you know i'm just authentically trying
to be myself and i'm literally doing the
best i can i really am
you know i i do therapy every week i
have a psychiatrist once a month i go to
meetings
i do everything i can i've always been
into self-improvement i've always been
into
seeing where my behavior is and where i
can change am i [ __ ] up guy yeah do i
have problems oh yeah a lot of problems
you know i mean but um you know so i you
know it's life and um
[Music]
from now on i'm just not i'm i'm i think
i'm unfuckable
[Laughter]
because you know i i've never gotten an
idea and i've never gotten a dm you said
this to me you've never gotten a dm i
mean
girls that's what i'm saying i i've had
girls that just send uh just titties
like hey here's some titties thought you
could start your day off with them to do
this yeah so i love them to do that yeah
i've never gotten a shoulder blade or a
finger or nothing from a woman but it's
fine but i told you once you say you're
single and you say that you're opening
the floodgates
you're gonna get some titties i don't
think so because i've asked for titties
before that's why you didn't get them
they're gonna yeah
they're gonna yeah yeah yeah and um
yeah yeah i've gotten dicks
i believe yeah yeah yeah
i don't like decks
yeah
but you know honestly i don't
it's funny i um
i i have no
i have
i don't want to see anybody that's what
i want so you're in a you're at a point
where you're not or you don't feel you
can make things right in this
relationship right now
yet you also don't want to go meet
someone no it's not about that i don't
literally don't want it i have no
interest
in compromising
in listening
even
in like being a government and
pretending you know i mean i have no
interest in that you mean i i i have no
interest of like what about you
you know i don't care you know yeah yeah
you know i don't care you know i mean
and it's like um
because i i have no interest of like you
know uh hey
let's go have dinner but you know what i
i you know i'm cutting out meat so let's
go to let's go to veggie grill right i'm
going to mortons
i'm just going to start dating you dude
yeah i'm going to martin's you have fun
at veggie grill i have no compromi i
have no room in my life to go i'll go
there right you know um with me it's
like you get this is what you get with
me all right and this is every ask any
girlfriend i've ever had right
is you'll get
some financial security in the sense of
like you know i i always pay for the
meal
i mean if you want to go to tulum
we'll go to tulum right um if you want
but it's like
you know one time this one girl was a dj
i dated a girl that was a dj like an
amateur and she's like i'm djing in a
club you know i mean downtown or a
little tokyo
i go have fun
like if she wanted me to go i just have
no interest
and that's the women don't like that no
they don't like yeah
though you know if they were like djing
with steve aoki
you know what i mean i think i'll go
that you know what i mean but it's like
i'll go one time
i'll go one time yeah i'll go one time
right but then it's like you're there
and then you know i mean you're like and
then you gotta lie like you're good i
don't know what good is
as a dj yeah i don't know you're lying
you're like you were really good when
you did the two things
it
was so good you know but like i don't
wanna i i'm lying you know i mean and
it's like
um here's another thing though what
that i want to say is is that like
i'm also very good at supporting what
you do like for instance right let's say
you're a girl all right and you're like
you know i like um
you know i like going into the mountains
and i like going to the rivers and i
like panning for gold okay that's your
hobby like your great grandfather was a
gold panda 49er yeah 49 is that what
they call yeah 49er right and i'd be and
she and if you were my girlfriend you
said i'm going to go to colorado i don't
know where they do it you know do they
do in colorado
i don't know if anyone does it anymore
i'm going to go to the mountains of
columbine i don't know is that a thing
yeah i don't know i'm going to the
mountains of columbine because that's
the only thing i know about
colorado because of the shooting
yeah yeah so i'm gonna go to the
mountains of columbine or and i'm gonna
go paying for gold for a month i'd be
like do you need money
to go
yeah i'll give you the money
right you go right just don't [ __ ]
anybody else right and i'm completely
for that right but if i play more than
two hours of video games it's a problem
do you understand what i'm saying yeah
so you're independently codependent what
does that mean meaning you like alone
time you like to be by yourself go over
there do whatever you want to do be
loyal have fun yeah enjoy it hell here's
some money i'll support it but i'm gonna
stay right the [ __ ] here and do my thing
yeah you know uh you like to be
starfield is going to come out in about
eight months i think you know i mean is
this the movie no it's a bethesda video
game right and they did fallout and
skyrim right and i know that when
you know when
starfield comes out
i'm going to be playing that thing 16
hours a day baby are you really oh
that's a thing yeah i don't give a [ __ ]
i'm playing it 16 hours a day and i
don't want to be in a relationship where
they're like you know
we're going to go to the park
you know and i want to do that yeah you
know i mean i think 50 and i was like i
don't want to do it
and i i'm sorry
if you
want to go to the park with your friends
i'm all for it yeah i mean and if you
want to go to mace maestros in between
video games and get a steak dinner
let's do it i'm your guy yeah and that
two in the morning you want to come over
and you want to give me a hand job let's
do it a hand job whatever it is i'll eat
your vagina you know what i mean i'll
eat a vagina you know what i mean
whatever you want you know what i mean
and i'll do it good i'll do the best of
my ability i'll do the best of my
ability right
so this is
so that's why i know from now on right i
feel like i'm just gonna be alone okay
so that's what i was gonna say so you've
accepted that there is no
human woman out there that's going to
say yes to that proposal you just
gave and you're you're okay with that
and you you don't blame them one bit
yeah you don't bla let me blame what
well i'm saying if they if someone if
you said look i'm gonna be playing this
game for 16 hours a day and they were
like hey no thanks you're like i get it
yeah no no no harm no no but here's the
thing though here's my thing okay is
if i wasn't making money
right
that's one thing right but i'd go on the
road if i book a movie or tv show i do
that i show up on time i know my lines i
know the character you know what i mean
i sold a couple of shows one with theo
vaughn at fox right
you know we're i'm gonna get the
showrunner for that i'm you know i mean
and i'm going to go into the writer's
room and try to figure this out right
and me and theo came up with the idea so
i i created creatively i do all the
things i need to do to make money and to
to be productive in that way right if i
was a guy that was just smoking weed all
day and doing that that's one thing
right but i'm not i'm not a loser right
it's just that i don't want to go to
veggie grill and you know i mean i don't
well this sounds like video games is
your golf
that's what i'm saying dude yeah how
long do you play golf for i don't golf
but i know those guys are out there like
six seven eight hours and [ __ ] yeah
right and for some reason golf seems
that's okay because if you're outdoors
you know man you're with your buddies
right but it's like spending more money
than you are on those video games right
right lessons clothes clubs balls tease
all of them yeah so you know um
that's where i'm at i'm also 50 and also
can i just be honest with you great
bobby thanks but i'm a
kind of chubbier old korean man now
in the market i don't know here's the
thing here's what it is i have yeah i
mean i have alpha man alpha male eyes
that's the thing right like i think god
intended me for to be with like a four
foot seven vietnamese girl named ning
ning right
or whatever
oh whatever you're right yeah like you
know i think that's what god intended
but i have alpha man of alpha male eyes
like you know all those dudes you know i
mean the comedy store that you know or
in the comedy right they're machismo i
have their eyes when it comes to like
attractive women right clyde is very
attractive right
so it's like i just feel like with this
new
approach you know i mean and with my
alpha male eyes
i'm just gonna be alone
and i'm okay with that
are you no
but i wouldn't have to be because it's
like
are you okay with it for a minute
at what point at what point do you think
it's going to be difficult too because
she's in your the same home what point
do you think you'll start longing for
that affection or or i don't think so no
no
do you not enjoy it
let's be honest
can we be honest for a second please
what i've realized because i've analyzed
every relationship i've ever been in
right in the first two years you know i
mean you're into it right because you're
you're getting to know the person you
know
um
[Music]
the mystery of it all
like when i first saw kalila naked i
cried
did you oh yeah i whimpered and i looked
the heavens and i said
thank you lord there is a god you know
what i mean this is like winning a
million-dollar lottery i appreciate it
you know
you know so in the beginning it's always
that right and if you get to know the
person everything's a mystery right
but after about three or four years
right the mystery goes away right and it
becomes
more of a friendship
and a compromise
and you have to start you know and
life happens right people get sick you
know i mean things happen you get old
you know i mean and it's like
it begins to fall apart
you know and it's like
i just why is that right and i just
think that it might the type of guy that
likes the mystery of it and the chase
and then once i have it you mean does
that all go away and what i found over
the years is it does for me so i have to
figure out
how how
i don't want that to happen again
right
and so on how do you bobby lee get over
that hump that's what you need to figure
out they break apart and i i want to
meet somebody where it just doesn't look
i get it i've never had a successful
relationship uh it's always either me or
them you know yeah i'm i'm
look i'm not easy
you know i'm set in my ways i'm i'm 49
i'm 50. so
also i say this all the time as
comedians what we do is a very selfish
thing it's a solo
sport it's not
it's not improv it's not a a a ensemble
it's not a [ __ ] it's a solo sport when
you're up there you're up there by your
[ __ ] self we don't see each other
unless we're on the same show in town
outside of that we're seeing each other
maybe in an airport here and there it's
a selfish and not in a negative way but
that's what selfish is it's all about me
and this is my thing that i'm doing so
i get it also as a comedian
how exactly how you feel with like i'm
good on [ __ ] veggie grill you know
yeah yeah yeah yeah i get it yeah it's a
selfish thing
here's another added element to my
situation is is that you know my
intentions with kalila is we're
continuing to do tiger belly
indefinitely well i mean that's very
mature too because why kill [ __ ]
something that's no we work great
together and we also have other things
that we're producing and things that
we're doing
and um she's my best friend and so
that's another thing it's like i have
that
with her you know i mean and so
i can't see a world where
i i have no interest you know i mean um
but every once in a while i would love
to see a titty
you know let's just a random titty on dm
you know i mean
but that's it you know i mean i don't
know maybe i'll change my tune you know
i mean this is fresh
for me and people change but um
you know with all that said you know i i
have no interest i um you know i want to
focus on
you know internal um things in terms of
just getting better as a human being you
know i you know
i also just let
the internet affect me you know yeah i
mean you've gone through a lot of [ __ ]
yeah especially for someone who has um
the issues you talk about openly to have
to go through
that amount of stress and anxiety the
last couple months it's been it's been
terrible it's been crazy yeah it's been
terrible yeah
yeah there's a lot of things going on
that people aren't even privy to that um
i'm not willing to talk about right but
um
yeah there are a lot of things that are
going on and um i just you know i just
as a human being
i buckled you know i'm you know and i
have to change and and so that's what
well i'd like to say this um
you can say you buckled i don't think
you buckled you bent a little bit but
when i saw you in the green room the
second time the first time i called i
lent you my support i gave you a hug
and i did say that the word the words
mastermind and bobby lee should never be
back to back anyway so that's how i knew
all that was [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah but
the next time i saw you in the in the
green room you were like i'm [ __ ]
bobby lee and i was like goddamn right
you are you're bobby [ __ ] lee yeah i
forget you know
what does that mean even like you know
it's so funny i know but everything to
you that's what the [ __ ] who the [ __ ] do
you think you're talking to yeah
it's a strange thing because it's like
you know you
you know we go to the grocery store
we're human beings right we we have the
same problems as everyone else i'm just
i'm a human being living on this planet
and i um you know i never think about
really
who i am or what i do right every once
in a while
a kid will come up to me and go nosotros
papaya or they'll say
i'm a bad friend or whatever it might be
and it feels great or i loved you on
this you know i mean and that feels good
but at the end of the day it's like you
know you forget about i don't know it's
a combination between
being in because that you know i i
struggle between being an egomaniac
and the king and a peasant
right like sometimes i i
feel like i'm the king
look at who me look at me
and then there's a lot of times and this
could fluctuate during the day where i
feel like i'm a piece of [ __ ] i'm a
loser and you know you know you go into
whatever that is you know i mean and i
just want to get to a point where i'm
just
who i am
and just in the middle somewhere you
know i mean that's really essentially
where i want to be you know
but yeah i am
so when i told you that i'm bobby lee it
was because i had spent
that for two three weeks going i'm a
loser you know i mean i'm a piece
because i read things online and
and stuff and i just you know that day i
saw you i was just like you know no [ __ ]
it i'm bobby lee you know i mean so it's
like um but i do want to find the middle
killer set i had a pretty good set yeah
but you know i want to be in the middle
you know don't you want to be in the
middle yeah yeah yeah
i mean look
let me ask you this thing because you
mentioned outside we were going to get
coffee you mentioned rehab so what
happened to how long ago was rehab and
and what
what actually made you finally say all
right i'm going to do it
the deaths of
um
bob saget and louis anderson yeah yeah
it was weird i um
i was using like you know i went to
mexico with santino to do the cancun
[ __ ] santino yeah santino the cancun
um just for laughs thing
and i was totally just i just
i had a vomit beard like you know i had
poo on my fingers i was [ __ ] up were
you drinking yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah i mean
i pull my fingers and vomit beers you
know i mean i was just walking out just
you know
days you know what i mean
and i had
a bunch of drugs on me it was really bad
and um is that the first time and how
how many years you used
a couple years you know what i mean but
um i had already been doing it for a
couple months but it was like now
getting out of hand where it was like 24
hours a day and this and that
yep and um
then i then bob saget and died
and then louis anderson died and then i
started coughing up blood whoa yeah
i started coughing up chunks of like
blood and i would send it to kala and
then go am i what the [ __ ] can't breathe
from drink just from the drinking no
from um i smoking cigarettes and so much
weed you know what i mean
and they were like balls of red chunks
of things and i in a napkin and i and
then
i just started thinking
i just convinced myself that i had
lung cancer
you know jesus christ
i'm next cuz i i also have i'm ocd so i
was like everything happens in threes
and i'm the third one oh my god i became
obsessed with it
right
and then i convinced myself i couldn't
breathe i would have these panic attacks
and i would be also drunk or high or a
combination between both things
and i just became imprisoned in in my
own mind you know and
i
started doing prayers you know i mean
like
please i don't want to die i don't want
to die i have too much to do and i um
i asked kalila book me into a rehab and
that's i went
that's essentially all it was you know i
um
it was the worst psychological one you
know i could probably last another year
or two
you know after that but
it was um
[Music]
yeah you know you're also when you turn
50 and you're acting like that you know
in
and then people not not that bob saget
and louie anderson are my age there are
a couple of generations probably a
generation or two above me you know i
mean but these are two people that i
knew
i wasn't as close to bob but he was very
nice to me but louie i used to open for
and stuff and i just thought
um yeah i just have too much to do you
know and i'm old
and i have to change i can't do this
anymore you know i mean your body just
kind of goes
whoa what i think that's what it was i
think my body was going we can't do the
[ __ ] that you were doing when you were
17. right you know
and so um
after i got out of the two i went to two
places
after i got out after a month you know i
and i lost was in a month yeah i lost
i had a movie
that had got booked with zoe dashnell it
was a pretty good movie
that when i was in rehab i lost because
i was in rehab oh man i lost a tv show
you know i lost things you know i mean
and when i got out i'm like you know i i
just equated all that stuff to be like
a result of doing
that kind of behavior and so i'm doing
everything i can
just not to get back there again you
know um
i want to do
the next
chapter of my life which i feel like is
my final chapter you know i don't know
how many chapters i have but you know
but
for the rest of my life i wanna
you know
i wanna do it
the best way i can in a healthy way
it's interesting um i when i worked for
uh oprah yeah you worked for oprah i did
i worked for oprah winfrey yeah there's
only one bro i don't know i don't know
for william
wait you were for oprah winfrey yeah
right here in l.a when she started her
network own the oprah winfrey network
yeah i was uh you ever talked to her i
met her one time yeah twice i met her um
i went and um
um i was a producer on her shoots and
stuff and they were doing shows so i got
to meet her get all their guests and
[ __ ] but i was very early in um setting
up her network out here and at the time
there was this thing they they called a
shift it would have happens in your life
and it sounds like you're going through
one right now you're shedding a lot of
old relationships that you've had for
some time
and it seems like this shift is coming
and i don't think it's necessarily just
because you're 50. i think there's this
time in your life where certain things
fall out the way they fall out and
you're in a shift and you're shedding
some people and things and maybe you
keep them in your life in a certain way
go ahead bobby lee what i want to say
though too is that
directly to the people out there you
know what i mean what i want to say to
the people out there is that
is
i don't have a problem with brendan
schaub
right
or callon or these guys you know i mean
i've known brian callan
for
20 over 20 years you know i mean we're
from the same show i mean he was on mad
tv before me but we're a part of that
family right so it's like i've been to
brian's house you know i mean i've hung
out with those guys many many times
right
i was just setting a boundary for myself
because they were saying crazy things
that had nothing to do with right you
are a unique mashup of all your favorite
things and there's a multitude of ways
to express yourself celebrate all that
you are and explore who you can be with
customizable prescription glasses from
pear eyewear look when i first got these
i was like i don't know how these are
gonna look let me test it out they're
awesome all right they've got so many
different colors so many different
styles the prescriptions are on point
then you just boom snap these little
magnetic pieces right over you look from
the side you can't tell i'm telling you
i'm very um
critical and i love these things all
right pair eyewears base frame and
magnetic top frame combination makes it
easy to switch up your style base frames
start at just 60 bucks including
prescription lenses there are hundreds
of top frame designs to match whichever
base frame you choose for every pair
purchased pair provides glasses and
vision care for children around the
world which is awesome and i love that
get glasses as unique as you are one
pair infinite style starting at just 60
go to pair eyewear dot com slash
honeydew for 15 off your first purchase
that's 15 percent off at p a i r eyewear
dot com slash honeydew it's summer y'all
lighten up that grass is great anytime
they can help you chill out before a big
meeting or be a new replacement to that
evening glass of wine they are the
perfect pairing to everything summer has
to offer dag grass is legal organic
smokable hemp that relaxes your body and
mellows your mind that grass cbd
products are made with 100 organic hemp
that's easy to dose and the effects come
on smooth they offer a variety of
products from their token smokable
pre-rolled joints as well as hemp flavor
and variety of cbd tincture drops enjoy
the effects of cbd while keeping a clear
head all dag grass products are
federally legal for ages 18 and over and
it ships right to your door anywhere in
the u.s so whether you're looking for a
new buzz or a chill way to enjoy an old
favorite dag grass will leave you in a
euphoric mood listen i'm telling you i
know some of the stuff out there is high
octane gives people panic attacks and
all that this that grass is great i've
even had their mom grass too it's
fantastic all right right now dadgrass
is offering my listeners 20 off your
first order when you go to dadgrass.com
honeydew go to dadgrass.com honeydew for
20 off your first order that's
dadgrass.com
honeydew now let's get back to the do so
it's like i'm not in a war with them you
know i just told them don't you know
normally these guys i would let people
talk to me in that way right
because in comedy obviously you know
that there are people that are
not like you like you and i think are
more similar in terms of like
our sensibilities you know i mean we're
a little sensitive no very yeah very
sensitive and we're um
you know little soft creatures
right and there are other people that
are like a more dominant
alpha-e right
and so it's like i usually just absorb
that [ __ ] but i'm like because of the
shift that you're talking about i just
basically said hey man don't talk to me
like that because i didn't do anything
right and um
we're done
why can't i do that as a human being you
can that's what i'm saying to another
human being so that's all that happened
but people online are like saying like
it's a war or there's a there's a
division there is no division right i'm
just a guy that says i don't want to be
talked to in that way i didn't do
anything
right it was
just out of left field it was just it
was very traumatic
and i don't need to
take that yeah my producer kirsten is on
the [ __ ] she's got her finger on the
pulse of everything podcasting and she
was telling me all the stuff that was
going on so i watched i watched your
episodes and i've talked to other
comedians about it as well and you've
been pretty open and honest about
everything out there yeah so i don't
blame you one bit
we were at a wedding together and i um
you know he was getting coffee
and i walked up to him and go what'd you
get
oh you guys i got a ice cr what are you
gonna get
you know i mean i go
i'm gonna get a double espresso you know
i'm
not that him and i ever gonna get back
to this place but it's like
i i feel like there's you know
well that was like a work function you
were performing yeah i'm trying to
figure it out you know i mean i'm i'm
trying to figure it out but um
boundaries are not allowing that anymore
yeah i don't allow it you know but um
that's all it is you know i mean it was
like um
i did i never had a problem with those
guys i love those guys in fact one of my
most viral things when it comes to
podcasting is on fighter than kid it's
like still out there you know i mean
it's a very funny bit
and um you know
we worked well together at one point
it's just
it just got out of hand you know and um
i don't know man it was
i wish it never happened but
and did that affect my relationship with
yeah you know it's it did
i mean a lot of that stuff affected it
it kind of um
put more fuel on something that you know
i mean that didn't need more fuel right
now and um that was already having
problems yeah and also i i
you know i don't know if
i think maybe a year from now maybe i
don't know i mean maybe i'll realize
that kawhila's the one for me and i'll
we'll get back i don't know
who knows what will happen but foreign's
like she's still gonna be right next to
you on the bed yeah yeah and we're i'm i
sleep we sleep great and
we communicate and um there's a lot of
crying and a lot of um
growing up that we're doing you know and
it's you know really it's tough but um
like i said man um i don't know what's
gonna happen i i know also that's
another thing it's like i don't
give a [ __ ] i'm not
you know
i don't want to live in the results of
anything
you know it's like
i'm not a fortune teller you know i
can't foresee i could die in a year i
don't know what's gonna happen right but
it's like the most important thing is
obviously the moment and um
the here and now
and i just need to l live in this space
you know because for my whole life i've
never lived here
i've never lived in the moment
everything was like what is it you know
how come this guy got that and how how
can i get that and what if this happens
and that it's just like not living you
know i mean
you're reacting to things that didn't
happen right
you're reacting to the things that
happened in the past right and it's like
it's no way to live and i can't that's
what the emdr therapy did that's what
i'm doing yeah that works the way
it is you had trauma
yeah so i i it's so funny because i do
it too i dr drew recommended it i
started talking to him about it and he's
like have you ever done it and i said no
he goes you would know if you have it's
not talk therapy so i went and um
i had been fine as far as anxiety and
things so or so i thought
and then my daughter almost got hit by a
car
and man did i come unhinged i got scared
to fly i got scared of heights just fear
fear fear and i couldn't shake it the
flights you know i'm like oh every bump
and i used to [ __ ] love taking off on
the runway i felt like a [ __ ] rock
star yeah and um i knew i needed to beat
it because we fly [ __ ] everywhere so
i went to emdr and i started working on
that
i mean i sleep on flights now yeah it
works yeah it works
your daughter almost getting run over
was the traumatic event that was the
[ __ ] thing that was made i was
laughing like uh like my trauma just
been laying in a hammock like oop here's
my there's my call yeah and here it
comes you know yeah and it had been
there all these years it just wasn't
triggered by anything and that fear
triggered it and man did it show up in
ways that i had never experienced before
yeah
there's a lot of incidences that
happened to me as a kid that i've worked
on with the mdr and it just it's i'm not
you might have it fully processed at all
but it's there any you're comfortable
talking about oh yeah i mean the one the
main one that i
i processed this you know my brother and
i used to
i'm just not funny
you know
it's a funny there's a comedy podcast
right this is not funny i'm doing just
fine he's not funny at all though man
all right anyway so my brother and i
we lived in minnesota
right and um edina minnesota
and um
dover drive that street we lived on and
um
my brother and i shared a room and i i
don't know how i was maybe eight or nine
my brother was six
and i remember distinctly remember
two three in the morning
being awoken to my mom being in my room
she turned the lights on and she opened
her mouth and her mouth was bleeding her
tooth was missing
right
and then
she was saying in korean
help me
um my dad's coming in
right
because my dad had punched her in the
face right and then i remember
my brother and i and my mom
barricading the door
holy [ __ ] yeah because my dad was coming
and i yeah
he was drunk
you know saying all kinds of say
and i just remember the fear
of that right
and um he opens the door we get i mean
you know he got in
and i don't remember what happened
afterwards right but i just remember
distinctly doing that you know what i
mean you can still see your mom with
that tooth knocked out oh yeah and she
was just in town because she did the uh
bad friends live oh yeah andrew right
and her the tooth that's missing she has
an artificial tooth there really but
it's like it stained a little bit right
so it always reminds me of it you know
what i mean but i've done emdr on that
incident right and there's a lot of
instances like that in my childhood
right and what that does is like you
know now as an adult
you know um you walk into every room i i
don't walk into a restaurant
or a comedy club like everyone else you
know i walk in and i look at everything
first
i look at the permit where it's safe
you mean where the exits are right
all that stuff right and i you know i
just look at life in a different kind of
way in an end in a cautious way you know
and that's all stems from you know how i
was raised and the experiences that i
have you know and i don't want to live
like that either right so i've i've done
there's a lot of and my mom used to be
very violent to me too so there's some
instances with that but it's like um
it's funny my therapist says that like
um if i didn't find comedy i would be
one of those
guys you know i mean that you know i
could have been
you know i mean a transient kind of a
guy you know i mean um if i didn't get
sober early on in my life i got sober
when i was 17.
there's a lot of choices that i made the
two things was getting sober
and also um starting to do stand up at
23
that saved me you know i mean because
you know i was able to
find something that you know i used as a
defense mechanism which is comedy and
humor
and um
because i was sober too that i could
walk through fear
you know what i mean a little easier
because
back then or still in aaa you know you
have this
higher power thing so i would you know
the third step is to turn it over right
so it's like what's that mean turn it
over to god so let god you know have
basically faith jesus take the wheel
yeah but not jesus you know yeah yeah so
it would be like
when i was 23 when i 23 and i started
doing stand-up i was so scared
but i would do that i go
i'm just going to turn it over and then
i'm going to um
just dive in you know what i mean
because um
you know
i want a big life
i've always wanted a big life and as a
kid living in the circumstances that i
did
you know i i always dreamed of something
different and better for myself you know
and um
so luckily i found comedy i mean luckily
if i lived in korea dude i'd be a
[ __ ]
i'd be carrying rice i mean
i'll get back and forth from between
funniest rice carrots
making everyone loud right i put the
rice on my nose or i was snort right
yeah i would do things yeah you know
what i'm saying right right i would do
tricks you know what i mean yeah
yeah yeah
but you're like i
you know i would be having some
ridiculous job like that right
but like so
luckily you know in america
you know i mean there are other options
thank god for podcasting like this is a
thing changed my life it changed my life
too you know so it's like um what i love
about this
podcasting
and i love this is what i love about it
is
you know back in the 90s
you'd come to la when did when did you
move to la
uh the second time 97 right
so when you come here so back then with
97 were you doing stand-up then no i did
improv first and then stand up
afterwards right but when you came here
you're like all right
do you there was like a blueprint
on how to make it i mean i had a loose
direction i just knew i needed to get on
stage right and that's why i figured it
out from there like i never once
considered agent manager none of that oh
really not in the very beginning the
first thing was like let me find places
that was an important thing that you
needed so you would you know a lot of
comics would hang out and they'd be like
who's your age are you sad you don't
mean all those things
and then you would go you would
contemplate them how do i get a sad car
you know what i mean and then they would
go you have to take acting classes so
you'd be in a meissner technique class i
mean spend all your money
right on like doing repetitions or
whatever right because you there was a
blueprint and then there was gatekeepers
like if these casting directors didn't
like you you're [ __ ] or if these
agents didn't like you you're [ __ ] right
or if this network said what you're
you're funny but we like these 10 people
right so right so it
those were it and if they didn't like
you you're [ __ ] out of luck right
but what the internet did was it you it
bypassed that it did not only did it do
that it also proved us right i knew i'm
not saying i'm funnier than anyone else
but i'm saying i know i'm funny enough
to make a living at this and be
successful at it and you're not giving
me a chance and these [ __ ] people and
these things let us go right over that
[ __ ] wall or under it or around
through it yeah and prove ourselves not
only right it's a big [ __ ] you back to
everybody else like look you're just
holding us back for nothing yeah why
because i look like an ex-boyfriend you
don't like you know what i mean it's
that dumb sometimes yeah it's that
[ __ ] dumb yeah yeah there is no
structure to this there's no like do
this for four years you do this another
two years you're this and then you're a
doctor you know a lawyer and you're a
judge none of that yeah none of that
yeah
so
so saturday i did a tiger barely live
we're at the ace
hotel theater in downtown sold it out um
1600 seats we did a game show on stage
right and
it was all tiger belly fans you know i
mean we did a
we did a q a for vips earlier and i got
really emotional people
got really emotional they were talking
about why they love our podcast and this
and that anyway during the show you know
packed it was killed i mean it was like
people stan it was insane right but my
asians showed up my agents not asians
asians
the asians showed up to asians
asians were there too right but like my
agents showed up and they're you know
they're wearing their suits and they're
in the back and they're like looking
around and they're mean and they're
and
eight years ago i called them and i said
can you help me with this podcast they
go well now we we do you know i mean you
do that on your own right
and you know i feel bad because you know
they don't get a cut of anything you
know men
right and they're you know i think i
don't know we're trying to figure it out
right there ain't no figuring it out i
know we are which i am trying to figure
it out don't you figure it out i'm
trying to figure it out to see what they
can do because i do love them
just let me finish let me finish what
i'm saying
all right let me finish what i'm saying
because it's my alpha all right
matt my agent right
he's been my agent since the 90s right
so it's like there is a relationship
there but
you know a long time ago when i asked
for help then they go we do bigger
things
podcasts are right at the time they were
like what are your numbers like we had
just started so i go a hundred dollars i
don't know you know i made 50 downloads
right like no no no right so they didn't
help they go you just do that on your
own so i did right
and now you know it's a thing right and
now
they'll want a piece of it right so it
was just kind of a cool
it was kind of not a [ __ ] you but it was
more of a this is what i did
this is what
you could have helped with
right
and you didn't
so now if you want something go get you
the mega deal
that's what i got
off of that that's what i said take this
[ __ ]
spaceship that i just took out the pluto
and take us to another [ __ ] universe
[ __ ] right and then you can have
it that's what i i had i had him an
agent tell me the same thing he's he
laughed and said come back when you're
making real money and i said that's
exactly when i'm not coming back
i know that's exactly what i said to
them i asked the same i asked my manager
i'm like look man if you can help me
between this is between the crab feast
and the honeydew yeah if you can help me
man we can do this and he just
wasn't he couldn't
and i'm like
i got it then i got to do this right
yeah then i got to do this on my own i
know and i wouldn't have it any other
[ __ ] way yeah i know i mean but don't
you think that it would have been nice
to get help
yeah yeah yeah of course it would but in
in the in hindsight i'm glad i did it
yeah i've learned so much yeah more
through doing all of this not just about
podcasting stuff but we've had producers
do shady [ __ ] and turnover you learn a
lot about people you know yeah i just
want to say i do
my agency
i'm not saying you don't thank you
you don't even need to say that i wanna
though go ahead yeah i i'm i love that
you said nothing wrong yeah no i do love
it i came
so now they got to do something with it
yeah
so what we said was it's funny because
we went there
and you know it's a huge build you know
the billion you know they have steven
spielberg and all these huge names right
radiohead or whatever right so that's
what they represent right and we're in
this beautiful conference room and it
was flattering for them to go you know i
mean like we want to help you know i
mean and it's cool but
you can't help but think you know i mean
wow
you know what i mean where were you
where would i i mean yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but i do
love them and you know i don't you know
thank you for everything
[Laughter]
so it's weird you know yeah i've been
watching you put your foot in your mouth
lately yeah i saw the emily [ __ ] on the
comedy story
dude
because i didn't see that first i saw
your apology first in person you're like
oh my god i saw that and then i saw the
clip and i was like
okay i want to tell emily this guy i
just want to say the reason why i said
that emily books for me i know and i
love my love i love her my sushi
honestly i love her and i have to say
this okay then she knows you do by the
way
deeply and not only that is is that the
reason why i did that right so let's say
for your audience i was on the comedy
store podcast and i lied and i basically
said
yeah i don't get spots either that much
you know i mean i think they only give
me spots on a loyalty is what i said
right and then i looked in the through
the window and emily was in the room
right and i go i'm kidding right but the
reason why i said it in the first place
is so that johnny could feel better
because he's not getting he's not
getting spots so i just wanted him to
feel better and that's what i did to to
soothe him
i honestly that's what it was you know
me because at the end of the day i what
i do get spots every time i call in you
know what i mean yeah you're there all
right so then i felt like a weasel
i got more spots than anyone else so i
felt like a [ __ ] weasel i felt like a
weasel you know what i mean yeah yeah
yeah but um i i want to say to emily you
know i mean i'll do anything
you know that's what you know that's it
yeah i apologize you know
i'm a [ __ ] weasel am i a weasel no
all right so what's up i want to know
what's next for you then you're just
going to take some time how to let me
ask you this forget this how do you heal
how do you move on when the person's
literally
under your roof in the bed next to you
how do you move
there's no healing there's no healing no
because you said you were heartbroken
you said those things we're both
heartbroken about it so how do you
unbreak your heart but over there what
was that
yeah
what's what soothes us is that we
have a deep
she's the love of my life i believe that
and i i know that doesn't mean it needs
to be intimate i know i know i love her
more than i i can't she's like
i'll tell you how i feel about her i
feel about her like i feel about my
brother
you know i mean in terms of like
like i'm gonna know this person
if she ever needed anything you know i
mean i would give her a lung
right
like that's how i feel about her you
know um
she's my best friend and um
i also
love our relationship
on our podcast and we work so well
together it's such a good yin yang you
know it is and it's interesting that you
know i'm just sitting here thinking
about it now and you guys as a couple
your child has been tiger belly yeah
you've built that from like you said 50
[ __ ] downloads everybody starts at
one download yeah we all started at one
yeah and you've built that together and
look at it now yeah [ __ ] thriving
it's thriving yeah yeah so to to have to
pivot in your relationship from this
um romantic boyfriend girlfriend couple
and to this professional couple and
still maintain i think it's pretty
impressive i know you're you're still
newly into it but well no i mean because
if you look at i think the real i think
you look at like
i don't know what chris pratt and anna
faris's relationship is it but it
doesn't seem like they're divorced i
know i know they're both remarried but i
feel like i feel like it's there's some
maybe some hostility or ugliness in that
relationship right right and i don't
ever want to be like that with kalila
right so i i i look at other hollywood
or like you know two people because you
know kalila and i
we're
you know
we're not a regular relationship our
relationship is out in the public we're
in the public eye right
and it puts a different dynamic on the
relationship you know i mean and so it's
like because we're in the public eye
and i i don't want to get resentful i
don't want the relationship to sour
and and have these deep resentments and
this and that so
we're mindfully doing it in a healthy
way so that we can still have our love
all right and still have a business
and still continue in that way you know
i mean and i and i i think we're doing
it if i i you know
we talk every night and i you know we
about how we feel and what's going on
and there's a lot of sadness like i said
well that's why i was asking about
healing you said there were tears and
things yeah i i mean i don't know i mean
we're in the process of it i mean i
don't know have you ever done that have
you ever broken up with someone that you
lived with and then stayed with living
with them
yeah but i've never been in a
relationship like this nothing like this
i mean every relationship i've ever had
was two years and i was out like
clockwork
like to the day that's what you said
yeah yeah yeah and this has been a
completely different thing although all
my relationships with previous
girlfriends have been really great and i
love them all you know i mean but
you know i you know the only one that i
really kind of talk to
that's around is sarah highland
you know i mean not from modern family
but the they're highly yeah yeah but
sarah hyland does our podcast she did
the live she's very close with kalila
you know and um
you know
yeah i
but you know sarah and i didn't
see each other after our relationship
for years and then it's she got married
to somebody jen rosenstein who's a
beautiful talented woman and um you know
now they're a part of our family you
know but um
i don't want to do that with clyla i
want to keep going and i want to you
know i want to see her every day and i
want to um we also have seven animals
bro
damn yeah a lot of atoms yeah yeah we
have seven animals that we got during
our relationship
you know and how do you split them apart
right it's it's like having children
i love every single one of them yeah i
mean deeply yeah you know i mean so it's
a it's a hard thing man bud
we're figuring it out is that an hour
yeah bro that went good huh great did
you like it i loved it
i wanted to say thank you very much for
coming on and talking about that i know
it's not easy it's fresh and all but
before i get you out of here i want to
ask you now after what we've talked
about going back to what you know about
yourself and everything you've said what
advice would you give your 16 year old
self
there's a lot man um
my 16 year old i would say
all those things that you think are
gonna fix you
[Music]
you know i mean these goals and
aspirations and all these things that if
only this happens or this
i promise you number one you will get
those things and number two you won't
feel any different
right so
get happy now
you know because
it's and i used to never believe that i
mean even as a kid you would hear a
great advice people would say you know
you know it nothing money or all these
it won't fix you and you would go [ __ ]
no it will you trust me i'm so stressed
out right now you have no idea i don't
know how i'm going to eat
yeah and those things do
alleviate right all these other issues
and i'm telling you right now there is
really no difference
in terms of how i feel you know i mean
so it's like i have to
do it now you know what i mean and also
at 16 i would say like you're gonna get
[ __ ]
you you'll get it you'll get it you know
because i was like
hate it
you will you'll see a vagina one day
right
you know i would because if i told my 16
year old son he would cry
because at 16 i thought
because in high school then no one
looked at me
i was like a you know a korean kid in an
all-white school
and
not that they were racist or anything
like that but i just was not that didn't
make you exotic
no no no because if i was like if i look
like a bts
you know i mean a tall kind of a good
looking maybe
right but i was like small too you know
i mean and kind of like wire you know
you know yeah you know the wiry and
eccentric i guess you know i mean and
it's like
yeah no i i thought i was gonna be
you know i mean an insult or whatever
right but i want to look at my 16 years
one day you'll see very good ones
[Laughter]
i love you too bud um promote whatever
you like again so bad friends tiger
belly and that's pretty much it all
right well thank you for coming on
everybody and thank you guys as well as
always ryan sickler.com ryan sickler on
all social media we'll talk to you all
next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you